are you building conversational
experience but would like to cut down
your design
and deployment time stick around as i
show you the pre-built agent templates
in dialogflow cx
hi i'm priyanka vergara in this episode
of deconstructing chat bots
i am going to show you how to decrease
your design
time by using dialogflow cx pre-built
agent template although we're not
traveling like we used to
we may be renting cars to get around
safely
let's see how our friends at alpha car a
rental company
can easily deploy a booking agent
imagine you are a manager at alphacar
and have noticed an
uptick in chatbot and email volume
but you have a small number of customer
service agents and not a lot of
experience
deploying a chat agent that is a perfect
scenario for a pre-built agent template
let's see how to set it up in the
console
the first step will be to create a
google cloud platform account
and a project if you already have one
don't worry about this strap
then go to the dialogflow cx console
click on the project we just created to
import the prebuilt agent
and click use pre-built agents we see a
number of templated agents that we can
import
for alpha car let's import the travel
car rental agent
select the desired location and create
we now have the foundational
architecture for our agent
let's see how the agent currently
functions best way to do that
is to navigate to the test agent button
and start a conversation
[Music]
now that we know how it currently works
let's modify some of the agents
responses to make it customized to alpha
car
starting with the default welcome intent
response on the start page
while we are here let's also modify the
sign off messages
at the end now let's take a look at our
custom entities
perhaps alpha car only offers a select
few cars so let's swap out the
mitsubishi mirage and nissan versa
with ford fusion and chevy malibu
we will add some synonyms and name
variations too
now that we've changed these custom
entities let's change the agent
option that are provided in the middle
of the flow
we are going to click on the mitsubishi
mirage and the nissan versa pages
and change the necessary information in
the entry dialog
in production these page options may be
fed by dynamic integrations with an
inventory crm
but for the purpose of this demo we will
hard code these options
now we have a customized flow for alpha
car
let's say alpha car knows they get a
number of questions about forms of
payment
and they want to be able to answer those
to contain their users
let's create a route group with a couple
of common questions
like what forms of payments do you
accept and
when will my account be debited to do
that we will go to create a route group
we will name it payment questions and
add routes
then we will create an intent for each
of those questions
with some training phrases once we've
added these training phrases
and the routes we save them we can enter
the fulfillment response now as well
for instance we accept visa american
express
and mastercard and your account will be
debited when you return your car rental
now let's add that route group to the
car option page under
add route type inside route groups
great now let's test the agent using the
simulator to make sure
everything's working as expected
[Music]
yay everything seems to be triggering
appropriately
now let's add this flow as a test case
test cases allow us to uncover bugs and
prevent regression
we can then revisit this flow and others
in the test case section
which allows us to rerun all the test
cases
import and export and view the test
coverage for transitions
and intents this will help us make sure
we're testing every part of the agent
it's also a good idea to look at the
validation section to see if there are
any recommendations or errors
it seems like it has spotted similar
training phrases across
multiple intents this can present nlu
confusion
down the line so best to resolve that by
deleting or modifying
selected training phrases let's fast
forward to being ready to deploy
we're going to want to use versions to
move our current development environment
into production
a draft flow is updated every time a
developer on our team makes a change
as a best practice we should always test
our draft flows before promoting them to
production versions although we can
always roll back to previous versions
if any problems are discovered with that
our alpha car agent is now live
all that's left to do is to regularly
look at the analytics section to improve
the agent by assessing how it's being
used in production
all right so we just created an entire
conversational experience to book a
rental car
in literally five minutes that's exactly
what pre-built agent templates are for
they increase the speed to market now
it's your turn
explore a pre-built agent that makes
sense for your project
and share your experience with me in the
comments below
you